a pocos días de cumplirse un mes de su
erupción el volcán cumbre vieja en la
isla española de la palma continúa
expulsando lava y enormes columnas de
humo y ceniza las autoridades no
vislumbran el cese de la actividad
volcánica que amenaza con aumentar su
devastación estos momentos lo que nos
dicen los científicos hoy habrá un nuevo
comité director que seguiré es que
todavía la posibilidad del
debilitamiento no está cercana
sigue habiendo deformidades en las zonas
del cono no se descarta que pueda haber
nuevas salidas de coladas la cantidad de
dióxido de azufre es alta entonces es
uno de los índices claves para decir que
está presto su final por tanto no sea
aventura que sea inminente más de 7000
personas fueron desalojadas de sus
hogares desde el pasado 19 de septiembre
el incesante magma de las 3 coladas que
ha arrojado el volcán cubre una
superficie de unas 750 hectáreas y ha
arrasado también con más de dos millares
de viviendas y cientos de campos
agrícolas este fin de semana el espeso
polvo volcánico causó interrupciones en
el aeropuerto de la palma que empezó a
permanecer abierto obligó a cancelar
casi la mitad de los vuelos tenía
billete para ayer que no puedo hacer hoy
que no puede ser
el barco que no está
el arma por lo menos en condición hablé
el otro día fui me fui sin irme porque
te pones de pie derecho ahí ha
masificado total los barcos cómo está la
situación de la pandemia que no tenemos
libertad total todavía y la verdad que
una situación muy complicada además de
la ceniza el ruido de las explosiones es
el paisaje habitual de los palmeros así
como los movimientos sísmicos cada vez
más frecuentes con al menos 42 sólo este
domingo